[Music]
advertising folks like to label
generations boomers Generation X
Millennials and now they call my
generation Generation Z these labels
help them put us in baskets so they can
group us by our unique wants and needs
and more effectively sell us stuff so we
are Generation Z the end of the alphabet
and that seems kind of appropriate
because if you look around there are
some pretty terrifying things going on
in the world
we got record temperatures all over the
world we got
thundersnow coral reefs dying ice
shelves falling into the ocean the Cubs
winning the World Series combustible tap
water and a reality show star president
okay so no poltergeists yet but we do
have these giant storms and if you watch
the news and commercials for clean coal
and energy voters it seems Generation Z
is being sold the idea that either we're
not really affecting the world with all
our human activity or if we are it's too
late to do anything about it we're a
group of youth filmmakers in New York
City and this all hit home for us in
2012 I mean it literally had our homes
hurricane sandy smashed us with a storm
surge of thirteen point eight feet we
wanted to find out the truth about what
happened why this happened and what our
generation could do about it this is our
journey to find answers we really didn't
want to evacuate because we evacuated
with Hurricane Irene and we thought we
were okay to stay here but my husband
stayed back and me and the kids went to
my mom's when the water was coming so
fast my husband kind of started making
phone calls to kind of say goodbye to us
and his mom he just thought if this is
it
he kind of made peace with it to get the
answers we were looking for we needed
experts so we spoke to the guy who
literally wrote the book on superstorm
sandy if their evacuations called people
should evacuate many of the people
killed in Sandy were people who were
under evacuation orders and chose to
stay we've had about a foot of sea level
rise in New York City since about 1900
of which maybe seven or eight inches is
due to global warming and that's the
influence that we're going to see
growing over time as the sea level
continues to rise as homes get repaired
I hope that they're getting repaired in
a way to make them more resilient to
future storms so elevated without the
utilities in the basement sometimes even
on stilts in some places these things
that make some of the homes that were
destroyed less likely to be destroyed or
damaged as badly next time this guy
works for NASA so you know he's super
smart right now we have committed
ourselves to a different climate than
the ones that are you know our ancestors
grew up in so the temperature of the sea
is still responding to the heating
produced by the increased greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere from decades ago
and if we just stopped emitting
greenhouse gases today you would still
see the temperature go on increasing and
in the ocean increase for four decades I
think New York believes that we're a
city that can't be touched so far they
need to happen to us
so it was like really surreal there were
any more buses or trains there was no
public transportation so I wasn't able
to go to school for like a week
the young people today are the ones who
are gonna have to deal with this problem
we as the people who have been on the
planet a little bit longer haven't done
so well at acting based on our you know
our children's interests above our own
shorter-term interests but the younger
generations hopefully can understand
this a little better because they're
gonna inherit this plan
so this all seems pretty grim I mean
it's a huge problem and it doesn't seem
like we can reverse it anytime soon so
is it hopeless we're just kids we don't
even get to choose what we get for
dinner or what times we go to bed much
less make big energy choices so do we
just give up I gotta believe the answer
is no I gotta believe that we can make a
difference so we went out and found some
other kids at the Green Schools Alliance
and ace that shared our sentiment
Alliance for higher education or ace for
short is organization that works
educating the youth on climate change
and what we can do to take actions
against climate change we have to start
by taking action to those in older
generations who aren't going to feel the
impacts as much so that we can have a
better future for ourselves and future
generations I know that a lot where
storms are coming and that people need
to be aware of our changing climate so
people should believe it scientific
studies more and not listen to the media
I hope people wake up and see that
climate change is happening people are
losing lives and homes like it's brill
how can you not want to change this how
can you not want to help it's important
to know not to lose hope if we don't
stop our co2 emissions it's only going
to get worse storms are only gonna get
bigger more people are gonna lose their
homes we don't have a choice we have to
do something I think we're the last
generation to actually help stop climate
change like after us I don't know
if we don't take a stand right now it's
only going to get worse I'm not an
expert I don't pretend to be but from my
life experience I feel like that
so-called hundred year storm is more
like a five year storm and that scares
the heck out of me I unless you are
throwing out everything your children
have made you from preschool to that day
and communion pictures and wedding
pictures and things that are stuff but
they mean something to you unless you're
throwing that all out you can't you
can't understand what it feels like and
five days in advance if they call for
another hurricane we're out of here
adolescence is very much about figuring
out who you are and what your values are
and maybe that is what this documentary
needs to be about about starting the
discussion with older generations I
lower my footprint by taking shorter
showers about what our values are about
who we are and what we want to be by
riding a bicycle because we don't
inherit the planet we borrow it from our
own kids
by using reusable water bottles and
going vegetarian about what products we
buy about the consumption choices we
make and about the leaders we choose we
need to make Generation Z generation
zero footprint we are the last
generation with the chance to stop
climate change the end of the alphabet
and we are going to do it to find out
more about what you can do visit us at
Gen zero org
[Music]
you
[Music]